well to follow up um kaminga apparently
had some thoughts any heart to- Hearts
between you and him between then and now
headed into this matchup or coaching
perspective to give as a response to his
apparent
thoughts uh we talked um you know
obviously those things are better um
discussed behind the scenes anytime um
something like that goes public um then
it creates um you know a distraction and
and um
I think you
know it's important for all of our guys
and I talked to our whole team about it
it's like you know you got got an issue
I'm here you know I am the most
accessible coach uh in the league
probably my doors always open and uh I
have players all the time come talk to
me um and I encourage it and it's um
it's a difficult situation because every
player um naturally has his own goals
his own dreams um everybody wants to
flourish everybody wants to Blossom um
and we have um a lot of guys who are
capable of playing and I have very
difficult decisions to make each and
every night JK is a young player who's
growing he's getting better it's why
he's start he been in the starting
lineup um and um you know he will
continue to grow and uh this is all part
of his growth then you kind of mentioned
it was a it was a Wiggins kaminga Choice
last night I know you've talked about
you know trying to find combinations
where they work together where are you
on that cuz I know you've you've
sprinkled some out there but it's still
yeah I mean we we would still like to
but we're obviously every game is tight
and we're trying to to win every game
and and um you know we want to put
ourselves in a a great position playoff
wise so um that's it's one of the the
challenges of this season really is is
um we're exploring combinations but at
the same time trying to win and so we
don't have uh you know a long time to
explore if something's not going well
and um at this point we're you know our
closing lineups have been different um
often night after night and so we
haven't been able to kind of find that
one fiveman group that we're uh just
automatically going to go to and that
that makes it tricky tricky for the
players and and tricky for the staff too
coach at this point this deep into the
season as you're continuing to hammer
out your rotation um playing as many
guys as you are is that creep into your
mind at all that
guys maybe won't be completely happy
with the minutes they're seeing in their
roles and that something will make its
way into public do do you think about
that at all yeah I played for 15 years
and if all 15 I was frustrated with my
playing time so this is how it works um
this is the most competitive uh
lucrative league in the world um every
team has you know 15 to 17 guys who are
all dying to play um everyone's
frustrated and so a big part of uh being
successful in this league is learning
how to navigate that frustration
learning how to just constantly put
yourself in a position uh to
succeed uh and you know as you grow as
you get better the the the more Talent
the guys have the more chance they have
of of really blossoming especially if
they're you know handling their business
and that's all part of the modern NBA is
teaching a lot of young guys um you know
how this how this has to
work